should we jump to the next Law and Order
story all right here you go you guys
ready system in uh in the criminal
justice system stealing luggage from
airports
in New York City the members of the
Biden Administration who commit these
crimes are given raises
former Biden nuclear official arrested
as fugitive of justice and Luggage theft
case Sam Britton stole bag from airports
in Minnesota and Nevada in 2022. he
probably stole a lot more than that and
I don't they called him non-binary I
don't think it was non-binary I think
he's a kleptomaniac and what he would do
is he would steal their clothes and then
wear them on camera because that gave
him some kind of exhilaration
like this is what he would do you can
see here in these images he's wearing
the clothing he stole from these women
it's I don't think it's about wearing a
women's clothing I think it's about
imagine this if he wore a suit nobody
would know there was a stolen suit yeah
you steal you steal a suitcase you find
a suit you put it on you wear it on the
show some of my bag is that my suit I
can't tell
but then in the suitcase is a suit and
is a frilly fancy dress with moons on it
and he's like this but you know he stole
it no for real he wants he wants to
stand in front of everybody and scream
this is a stolen outfit that I am
wearing and smile as they clap for him
that's what does it for him yeah that's
what that's that's what he gets and the
bite Administration is all about it man
that's some sick fetish types you can be
weird but you know just don't be weird
around our kids don't be weird you know
in public you know do whatever you want
to do this is America it's freedom of
you know we have so many freedoms here
so do whatever you want to do behind
closed door just don't do weird stuff in
public and don't do weird stuff with my
luggage
that's all that's all we're asking is
like leave the kids alone and don't
break laws yeah dude it's like a
two-hour desk would you get that little
airplane
fly and get that little slip in your
luggage that says you've been subjected
to a random TSA search you can't find
your dress you look on television this
guy's wearing it you're like wait a
minute that's that's it's yeah
that's literally what happened what was
he did he was like a nuclear regulation
guy he's so weird like how why was he in
the news
he wasn't like a prominent admin a
Cabinet member because it was his
non-binary scene he was like abiding
appointment I think he was uh I think he
was a groundbreaking pick or something
like that was nuclear diversity which
makes us stronger yeah former nuclear
waste expert from the for the Department
of energy they were like he's non-binary
it turned out he was just some kind of
like klepto fetishist what would you
call the kleptophilia something like
that yeah that's got an arousal from
stealing but Ophelia that's what they
call Mr Steal Your Girl You Know What I
Mean
Sheamus uh
I I mean I think I'm if I understand
correctly the only reason that he got
appointed is because he was you know
they could they could promote that they
had a non-binary a member of the the new
religion uh in the uh position klepto
lagnia by the way what kleptolagnio
lagnia that's a l-a-g-n-i-a what what is
that yeah that's what
uh the state of being sexually aroused
by theft
yeah yeah
uh so I learned another term that
shouldn't have to exist the other one
we'll talk about in the members only
show yeah we gotta we gotta we got a
outrageous members only show come up
here tonight having to do with a lot
have you found me on Twitter you know
what I'm talking about
like we don't we don't we don't say such
things on YouTube
no I don't think I even said anything
too egregious on Twitter I guess but we
stated a fact well let's just we'll save
it let's keep let's keep talking about
the crazy guy who stole the clothes
[Laughter]
what did he steal he said he was ordered
to pay over 3 670 to the owner of a bag
he stole some one of the one-of-a-kind
stuff that's um that a lady had made
she'd made her own clothes and stuff and
it was like expensive for her to make
and it was one of a kind and and he
jacked it and then I think actually that
yeah the one on the right there that
that uh the red thing was was custom
made actually no maybe even the I think
both of those I I think custom made he's
wearing these one-of-a-kind artistic
modeling pieces like the clothing he's
wearing was designed he probably stole a
bunch of bags and threw away all of the
stuff from Kohl's in Old Navy
and then he finds the unique stuff and
says it's it's basically like returning
to the scene of a crime you know like in
the in the movies and the serial killers
like standing outside the police line
smiling and staring and they're like
What's this guy doing they can't prove
anything what do you do like that's what
he was trying to do and I think
it's it's like uh what was it was it was
it King of the Hill or whatever what
show was it where oh no Family Guy did
it where Lois is stealing everything
because she gets excited from it oh yeah
and then she like puts the cigarette on
her arm like I'm alive like instead of
skydiving or bungee jumping this dude
steals women's clothing and then wears
it on TV Lois does have an addictive
personality and Peggy Hill was a
sociopath like she's like a narcissistic
sociopath serious yeah she's very into
herself
that's an understatement she was an evil
woman that character man that's what
inspires people like this I guess who go
around stealing clothes yeah it's like
this dude's from one of those shows it's
just it's real life it's like it feels
like a thing you'd see on Family Guy but
this is something that actually happened
like numerous times yo he was as part of
an adult diversion he was required to
write a letter of apology returns stolen
items to the victim and complete three
days of community service Brenton also
agreed to undergo a mental health
evaluation oh my gosh wow because he was
facing five years in jail he had to pay
3670 bucks over a bag he stole in
December from the Harry Reid
International Airport he was seeing
surveillance footage of the stolen bag
in July
at the time of his arrest in Vegas the
Biden admins at the incident of an
alleged crimes were non-political uh
where a non-political issue refused to
comment in February 2023 a houston-based
fashion designer publicly accused him of
stealing her bag from Reagan National
Airport in 2018
Isaac Thomson wrote on Twitter that she
had lost a bag containing custom outfits
after traveling to DC to display her
designs at an event after Brenton's
thefts were reported by the media
Thompson said she recognized her items
in the images of Brenton filed a
complaint with police in Houston and was
subsequently contacted by the FBI well
at least they're doing something I guess
you know
if anything they're stopping this guy
from stealing clothes yeah they're also
suppressing information but why why like
so if he already got arrested and
charged what's the current arrest for he
was taken into custody May 17th at his
home in Maryland at the request of the
Metropolitan Washington Airport
he was taken to the Montgomery County
Detention Center and held overnight in
prep for an appearance before judge
Victor delpino on May 18th which was
today he is being held without bond yo
that's like really close to here it's
like that's like a few miles away can
you imagine being a grown man and being
forced to write an apology note
the worst thing I've ever heard did he
have to write it 50 times on a
chalkboard I will not steal women's
luggage I will not steal him his life
tough one
man I just I I can't wait for him to
take the present time
so you're like oh I'm so sorry for it's
like 30 30 some odd miles away from here
wow it's like that's like relatively
close I guess we're super close to DC so
it's not surprising yeah oh that's right
by it's right by um who's that member of
Congress who uh lied about me and
everybody else on the January 6
committee uh Rat Raskin oh okay yeah
he's right by right by there
the uh the designer that he uh stole
from
I can't pronounce that I'm a asherman
Thompson Thompson I don't know that's
what it is that what is that asaya
Thompson Thompson one yeah and I mean
she's still out there doing stuff and
she makes cool stuff but man
he got himself into a pickle
has any one of a kind has anyone gone
through any of his other photos and like
trying to track try to track down
yeah his clothing I think someone did
actually I think someone that's how they
found some other stuff no way yeah they
were like oh my gosh
wow yeah it definitely has more the
adults are back in charge as they say
that's the crazy thing it's like the uh
that what they say is always the
opposite
the adults are back in charge and
they're clearly not Pete booty judge
isn't even oh did you see that that that
uh article about people to judge
that said yeah he was a genius yes and a
bunch of other crazy I should pull this
one up dude did you guys remember in the
2016 election like right towards the end
there right before it was time to vote
you got all of these people claiming all
these people in the media is saying oh
yeah like I know people who worked with
Hillary they said she's super nice it
was all it was like that's really weird
that this is the first time I'm ever
hearing it and I heard it like five
times on the radio in the last week well
I mean look the media has been in bed
with the Democrats and with the you know
the clintons and and probably the Obamas
and stuff for the better part of at
least a decade so for them to just say
oh hey this is the person that we
endorse and and run propaganda another
thing there was a there was a law that
prevented the the federal government
from propagandizing the American people
and that was repealed in one of the
ndaas when when uh Barack Obama was in
office I think it was like 2011 or
something like that but there used to be
a law that said the government cannot
propagandize the American people that
law gets repealed in ndaa next thing you
know social media companies are doing
their best to shove whatever the
Democrat Party wants down in people's
throats and actually they feel obligated
to right I mean probably because they've
well no they felt so bad that Trump got
elected they just needed to make sure
something like that didn't happen again
yeah
I blame CNN Jeff Zucker among other
things they uh they were so obsessed
with them they did us all the favor and
gave him free five billion dollars in
Free Press coverage and so now they're
terrified their ratings are lower than
Newsmax because they don't seem to get
it if you want to be a member of the
cult you got to be a full-fledged member
of the culture but you can't try and be
a cult member and a journalist because
then they don't but but they had Donald
Trump on a Town Hall they had the front
runner for the Republican Party On TV
and they they debated him and that was
not good enough yeah and so they're
losing audience members for doing so
yeah they that look CNN you want to be
in the cult be in the cult if CNN
reported real news they would have
tremendous ratings could you imagine if
the entire time scene existed they were
pushing back on russiagate lies they
were saying like these these reports are
not true there's no evidence to adjust
it then people would be watching them
and all they had to competing with Fox
News all the had to do was tell the
truth right like you could tell an
unbiased truth like factual story The
the way that Donald Trump was covered
for his entire presidency once he got
into office if you covered any other
president in the same way with that much
negative press you're going to have a
population that believes that he is evil
because the average person doesn't spend
the time necessary and they shouldn't
honestly they should go out and do
things with their lives and live their
lives yeah but they don't spend the time
necessary to really dig down and be like
well this isn't true that they said and
that isn't true there's so many people
that still to this day believe that
Donald Trump uh the very fine people lie
about the the
um unite the right rally the way that he
was talking about it there's still
people that believe that and that's
probably what your average low
information voter thinks thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there